[Música]
Pues llega la economía aquí a directo a
América edición nocturna Para ello
tenemos a nuestra compañera Daniela
hablando aquí en el estudio de Daniela
bienvenida Muchas gracias Rodrigo Hola y
vamos a empezar hablando de una gran
empresa tecnológica de Google que da un
paso más hacia la integración de la
Inteligencia artificial en sus servicios
tenida Inteligencia artificial en lo que
ha llamado la Inteligencia artificial
generativa que va a ayudar por ejemplo a
redactar correos desde el celular con
algunas palabras clave que le dé el
usuario también a crear presentaciones
profesionales o analizar contenidos en
hojas de cálculo de una mejor manera
aunque esta herramienta solamente estará
disponible en unas semanas para un
período de prueba y con lista de espera
inicialmente Google ya tiene un chatbot
llamado Bart que compite con el chat de
Microsoft y anunció que hoy estará
disponible en 180 países
siete años después de nuestro viaje como
primera empresa de Inteligencia
artificial nos encontramos en una
emocionante punto de inflexión Tenemos
la oportunidad de hacer que la
Inteligencia artificial sea aún más Útil
para las personas las empresas las
comunidades para todos hemos estado
aplicando la para hacer nuestros
productos radicalmente más útiles por un
tiempo con Inteligencia artificial
generativa estamos dando el siguiente
paso para Daniela hay ejemplos de lo que
puede cambiar con esta Inteligencia
artificial y espero que de momento no
nos digas que tú y yo vamos a ser
prescindibles no vamos a quedarnos acá
por un buen rato hay nombres sin embargo
sí de empresas que van a empezar a
utilizar esa Inteligencia artificial que
van desde el call center de doge Bank
hasta Victoria secreta o desde funciones
tan simples como por ejemplo un chat
votos de servicio al cliente para Uber
muy normal hasta otras más inusuales
como la Inteligencia artificial que hace
los pedidos para llevar en un Drive true
de la hamburguesería Wendy's Bueno pues
veremos hasta dónde llega esta
Inteligencia artificial nos vamos a ir
ahora a Brasil para hablar de Telegram
que estuvo a punto de suspender su
actividad en este país Bueno ya hemos
venido hablando desde hace unos días que
en este país se está discutiendo un
proyecto de ley que busca ponerle freno
a la desinformación en internet y las
grandes compañías del sector se han
mostrado en desacuerdo Telegram envió en
las últimas horas un mensaje a sus
usuarios en Brasil que decía que la
democracia entre comillas está siendo
atacada por esta iniciativa el tribunal
supremo ordenó un bloqueo de 72 horas y
fuertes sanciones si Telegram No
retiraba ese texto la empresa lo cumplió
de inmediato no solamente lo
retiró sino que rectificó el texto que
decía que ese proyecto iba a acabar con
la internet moderna y aceptó enviar otro
mensaje masivo advirtiendo que su
comunicado anterior era una flagrante e
ilícita desinformación que atentaba
contra El Congreso Nacional Contra el
poder judicial el estado de derecho y la
democracia brasileña todo por orden del
supremo Bueno pues vamos un poco más
arriba del continente hasta Estados
Unidos porque allí Joe biden ha
insistido no sé si a través de Telegram
o vía normal
pues sus canales oficiales que no es una
opción que Estados Unidos caiga en
default no y es que quedan menos de tres
semanas para este temido primero de
junio en el que el país podría caer
eventualmente en un incumplimiento de
deuda por primera vez en su historia si
es que el congreso no aprueba subir el
techo de deuda que hoy están 31,4
billones de dólares los partidos no han
podido llegar a un acuerdo los
republicanos exigen que el gobierno se
apriete el cinturón y la Casa Blanca los
acusa de chantaje
si no pagamos nuestra deuda todo el
mundo estará en problemas Esta es una
crisis fabricada no hay duda sobre la
capacidad
tenemos la economía más sólida del mundo
y deberíamos recortar el gasto y reducir
los déficits sin una crisis innecesaria
de manera responsable pero
y otra opción que aparece ahora encima
de la mesa pues es una de las cartas que
tiene biden sobre la mesa que es
saltarse al legislativo e invocar la
enmienda 14 a la Constitución de Estados
Unidos que buscaría declarar
inconstitucional el solo hecho de que
exista un límite de deuda Eso quiere
decir que el presidente tiene el deber
de garantizar que las deudas se paguen
se apruebe o no el tope según está
enmienda biden no lo ha descartado pero
sí es consciente de que hacerlo
requeriría un litigio porque no deja de
ser una interpretación de la
Constitución que siempre tiene pues
varios lados y llevaría un nuevo debate
probablemente eterno entre demócratas y
republicanas Daniela cifra del día 155
millones de dólares por este valor se
subastaron unas 100 joyas pertenecientes
a la multimillonaria austriaca Heidi
horten Quien murió el año pasado de los
81 años con una fortuna de 2900 millones
de dólares según la revista Forbes
Cuál es de lo llamativo que su marido
alemán hizo su fortuna mientras estaba
afiliado al partido nazi la subasta fue
celebrada en medio de críticas de grupos
judíos Pese a que la casa de subastas
crisis argumentó que las ganancias se
iban a destinar a la investigación y
educación sobre el holocausto Pues esta
colección completa será subastada a lo
largo de este año y tiene 700 joyas
incluidas piezas de diseñadores del
siglo 20 como Cartier y bulgariya muchas
gracias por este repaso económico sigue
con nosotros Porque nos vamos ahora